masterpiece
flawless two words I've heard thrown
around about parasite more than any
other film in recent memory I think what
sets parasite apart is the level of
attention to detail here's an example
bong joon-ho wanted to use sunlight as a
way to illustrate the better life of the
upper-class they're higher up in society
higher up physically and therefore
closer to the Sun so in the film the
first time we see the Sun itself on
screen is one ki-woo from the lower
class kin family ascends a staircase
towards the upper class Park family's
house the position of the park house set
was constructed specifically with the
movement and direction of the Sun taken
into account to make this shot possible
parasites set design and the way bong
joon-ho uses visual language to
construct the world that surrounds these
sets is a vitally important aspect of
the film's themes understanding how bong
joon-ho is using set design in this film
helps us understand what the film is
really saying about class structure
spoilers ahead
this video is sponsored by YouTube
Tyler Mallory click the link in the
description to check out his channel
where he does great video essays about
screenwriting parasite is a tale of two
houses one lower class and one upper
class after watching the film I was
surprised to learn that not only was it
a park family home built for the film
but so was the Kim family semi basement
home and the entire block that surrounds
it
great design subtle but effective use of
CGI and a reliance on natural light
keeps these sets from feeling like sets
but more than just looking and feeling
realistic the details of these sets and
how they're portrayed in the film plays
a key role in constructing the film's
themes each house features a prominent
window one looks out at street level one
over a manicured lawn these windows are
both slightly unusual and shaped similar
to the shape of the film's own 2.39
to one aspect ratio in a way our screen
is the window we the audience get to
view these two houses through just how
much I'm doing one and through careful
cinematography these two houses seem to
face each other this impression is
created with how these windows are shown
early in the film and the beginning of
the film director bong uses the 180
degree roll to set up a line of action
between the two windows shooting them in
the same way you would shoot two
characters and conversation the Kim's
window is always shot from the right
side of the room and the parks always
from the left it's subtle in these early
scenes the parks window is only really
shown in the background but it sets up a
feeling that the Kim's house is on the
Left facing right and the parks house is
on the right facing left it's the same
visual design director bong joon-ho used
in snowpiercer
to illustrate class structure with its
lower class towards the back of the
train and on the left of the screen and
its upper class to the front of the
train and on the right of the screen in
parasite director bong adds to this
design the houses face each other from
left to right but they also have a clear
vertical relationship leaving the poor
family's house you have to ascend
stairs just to get to the street
entering the rich family's house you go
from the street upstairs into the house
elevation is used continuously
throughout the film to almost literally
illustrate on screen the class
separation between these families in the
parks house you go up a staircase to
their bedrooms and the Kim's you go up a
staircase to the toilet when the Kim's
hide like cockroaches from the light of
the park family they literally hide
below the parks oh yeah how do we portal
in scenes in the Kim's neighborhood the
streets behind them often seemed to
slope upward giving the impression that
there's always something above them in
the parks neighborhood the roads lead up
towards the park house or sloped
downward away from them director bong
uses descent and emphasizes the vertical
distance between the classes in the two
most stunning moments in the film
throughout the film the distance between
the two houses isn't really Illustrated
when the comes walk we don't see their
journey and when ki-jong is driven home
we don't really get a sense of the
distance or the elevation change but
when the Kim's plan goes awry we do get
to see the distance between the houses
and alongside that we clearly see the
descent every shot as the family runs
from the park house to their own leads
of them downward their place in the
upper class home was really just an
illusion during this scene we truly see
and feel the sheer amount of separation
vertically between the two homes
[Music]
the reveal of the bunker and the man
living underneath the house also uses
descent the long take as the camera
careens down the stairs emphasizes the
descent as much as possible
the staircase feels almost impossibly
long
this is a fairly simple and elegant use
of visual language to communicate a
concept it's something most viewers will
catch on their first or second viewing
but this use of spatial layout and
snowpiercer and parasite isn't just a
neat way to illustrate class separation
in the films I think it's crucial to
understanding what director bong is
actually saying about class with these
films
I don't think parasite can simply be
condensed as these rich people are bad
and parasitic or these poor people are
bad and parasitic on the surface we see
the conflict as being between these
three families but mr. Kim's aggression
against mr. Park is misplaced in a way
when the park family is pushed out of
their home another family moves in the
Kim's are still in their semi-basement
home it's not the family but the layout
the structure that causes the problem
and none of the characters seem to see
this key was planned to rescue his
father at the end of the film is simply
a plan to buy the house advance upward
in the class structure and become the
park family to another point moon you
put this I assumed he thought it alone
not in a tunnel um what I'm Tony secure
the structure affects us the audience
too we root for the Kim's not because
they're better people than the parks the
Kim's lie cheat and hurt other innocent
people to get their way
the parks looked down on those below
them the things of who looks
and the mama loosening the rule [ __ ]
boots your 39mm FIFA
but the Kem's judge the Rich Dad listen
Jean do without even do it editing audio
so the parks prioritize their own
family's troubles over the troubles of
others but the Kim's do the same thing
we root for the Kim's though because
they're the underdog their place in the
structure is why we root for them and we
don't root for them to reform destroy or
break out of that structure we simply
root for them to scale it to climb to
the top themselves but by illustrating
class structure with set design
something that feels more permanent to
the audience I think bong joon-ho is
articulating something about that class
structure he isn't just illustrating the
problems at causes but in parasite and
snowpiercer both the difficult and
complex nature of solving those problems
key Wu's plan is a fantasy but even if
he succeeded
that's only one family that has elevated
itself you might be able to move a
family from one end of the spectrum to
another but you can't remove the
physical separation between this house
and this house
thank you to tyler mallory for
sponsoring this video
he does a lot of great content on his
channel about screenwriting
but i want to highlight one specific
video here recently he made a video
about writing a screenplay in 48 hours
day 2 it's 9:02 a.m. i don't know if he
can hear to my voice but i woke up
feeling kind of sick today but that's ok
i'm feeling energized and we're gonna
pound this out get it done I'm gonna be
great he walks you through his entire
process the struggles that he dealt with
and how he overcame them it's a really
informative and inspiring watch click
the link in the card to check out this
video or click the link in the
description to check out his channel and
subscribe I've learned a lot from his
channel about screenwriting and if you
want to learn more about that check out
his videos for free on YouTube thank you
so much for watching this video every
month I make a bonus patreon video this
month's video is about jump cuts in the
irishman if you want to check that out
head over to patreon Comus flight to
sign up and support my channel
[Music]